this is the Central Dispatch for
Guatemala City's bomberos balloon patios
a small army of volunteer firefighters
and paramedics they route thousands of
emergency calls watt Amala city is a hub
for the narco trade and one of the most
violent places on earth every year one
out of every 1,500 residents living here
is murdered Guatemala city's official
government first responders the Bombadil
smoo news palace won't even acknowledge
the existence of a gang and violence
problem but the voluntarios tell a very
diverse
[Music]
municipal is receiving a port economic
Oh del gobierno de la municipal EDA you
staining mess equipo tinning separation
came as gente pero la confianza que la
gente tiene nosotros es porque nosotros
somos de todos que pareció que zone
select Evo's in en su trabajo nosotros
Casa most all as evening approaches Diaz
gets his first call a gunshot in the
place was a woman who has received a
gunshot in she's helped solve another
call interrupts with you later
it turns out this call is for another
gunshot to the head in a different
ambulances 22 year old Javier via Toro a
college - who moonlights as a volunteer
para nada es algo que realmente me gusta
me a persona
me gusta la gente que no tiene Mucha
necesita oriental honestly see the norm
of pulling over for the ambulance is not
well established in Guatemala City so we
sit in traffic for several yards we
finally arrived at to see a drunken
Carla no injuries the drivers turn
around and cruise back to the station
blasting sin 80s June
[Music]
the next call is another gunshot like
them protocol
he's dead upon arrival shot through the
head from behind another unit will take
him straight to the morgue after the
police cleared the crime scene
but I'm hugging into this is also
Telemachus on the Lenape place when the
stairs are gonna scar - overt Centennial
momentous event
based on his near daily encounters with
execution-style murders in the city
Xavier doubts this one will ever get
solved the balloon tarios
are beloved in guatemala their Central
Station is littered with large and
mostly useless emergency vehicles
donated to them by well-meaning
individuals and groups who don't
understand that they don't have the
resources and expertise to maintain them
they face a rising and unrelenting tide
of violence and destruction largely
fueled by gangs who use the money and
power gained through the drug trade and
street crime to purchase political
influence and silence critics many
people in Guatemala avoid talking about
the drug war or the street gangs talking
is just another way to end up flat on
your back with a bullet hole through the
back of the head
the bomberos don't stop to ask who or
why or why that's someone else's joke
their job is to save lives and according
to many citizens in the city they do it
better than their official government
sanctioned counterparts you has a
satisfaction inside you that help you to
be okay God is a very important part of
this because he viewed on say God please
let me help you my brother or people I
don't know you can lose it
[Music]